So in 1853, during the California Gold Rush, a leafleteer out west published the "Ten Commandments for Gold Miners" who'd come out to prospect. Commandment number four-- commandment four in the traditional Ten Commandments tells you to observe the Sabbath day to keep it holy. Commandment number four reads like this, "Thou shalt not remember what thy friends do at home on the Sabbath day, lest the remembrance may not compare favorably with what thou doest here."
1853年加州淘金热期间，一位西部传单撰稿人发布了《淘金者十诫》，送给那些前来寻找金矿的人。第四条诫命——传统十诫中的第四条要求你在安息日这天守为圣日。第四条诫命是这样写的：“在安息日，你不可惦记你在家乡的朋友在做什么，以免那种回忆让你觉得眼下的生活不如意。”
For commandment number eight-- the commandment about stealing in the traditional commandments. Commandment eight, "Thou shalt not steal a pick or a shovel or a pan from thy fellow miner or take away his tools without his leave, nor return them broken, nor remove his stake to enlarge thy claim, nor pan out gold from his riffle box."
第八条诫命——传统诫命中关于偷盗的那一条。第八条诫命：“你不可从你的矿工同伴那里偷走鹤嘴锄、铁锹或金盘，未经允许不可拿走他的工具，归还时不可弄坏，也不可为了扩大你的矿区范围而挪动他的界桩，更不可淘走他洗矿槽里的金子。”
There is the "Ten Commandments of Umpiring," written in 1949 by the commissioner of Major League Baseball. Commandment number one, "Keep your eye on the ball." Four different commandments on this list are, basically, about not getting mad at the players.
1949年，美国职业棒球大联盟的专员曾写过《裁判十诫》。第一条诫命是：“盯紧球。”这份清单上有四条诫命基本上都是关于不要对球员发火的。
There are the "Ten Commandments of Tractor Safety." Number one, "Know your tractor, its implements, and how they work." The "Ten Commandments of Paris Dining," assembled by Fodor's Travel Guides, which include number two, "Thou shalt not be too familiar with the waiter. Don't expect to hear, 'My name is Gaston, and I will be your server tonight." Also, number eight, "Thou shall not assume that the customer is always right." And number 10, "Thou shall never use the term 'doggy bag.'"
还有《拖拉机安全十诫》。第一条：“了解你的拖拉机、农具及其运作方式。”由福多尔旅行指南汇编的《巴黎用餐十诫》包括第二条：“你不可对服务员过于亲热。不要指望听到‘我叫加斯顿，今晚将由我为您服务’。”此外，第八条：“你不可想当然地认为顾客永远是对的。”还有第十条：“你绝不可使用‘打包袋’这个词。”
Let's see what else. The "Ten Commandments of Cell Phone Etiquette." Number four, "Thou shall not wear more than two wireless devices on thy belt." The Ten Commandments of Sports Betting, the "Ten Commandments of Protecting Your Million Dollar Idea," the "Ten Commandments of Good Historical Writing." My favorite-- number 10, "Thou shalt write consistently in the past tense." Interesting to think that you would need that.
看看还有什么。《手机礼仪十诫》。第四条：“你腰带上佩戴的无线设备不得超过两个。”体育博彩十诫、《保护你百万美元创意十诫》、《优秀历史写作十诫》。我最喜欢的是第十条：“你写作时必须始终使用过去时。”想到你竟然需要这条诫命，真是有趣。
The "Ten Commandments of Bilingual Blogs," the "Ten Commandments of Pastors Leaving the Congregation," the "Ten Commandments of Working in a Hostile Environment," the "Ten Commandments for Communication with People with Disabilities"-- this includes a very helpful number six, "Don't lean on a person's wheelchair." Or number 10, "Don't be embarrassed or freak out if you accidentally use a common phrase like, 'See you later,' with somebody who can't see, or 'Did you hear about that?' with somebody who can't hear."
《双语博客十诫》、《牧师离职十诫》、《在敌对环境中工作十诫》、《与残障人士沟通十诫》——其中包含一条非常有用的第六条：“不要靠在别人的轮椅上。”或者第十条：“如果你不小心对视障人士说了‘回见’，或者对听障人士说了‘你听说了吗？’，不必感到尴尬或惊慌。”
The "Ten Commandments of Being a Math Teacher"-- this will actually reveal a lot about the internal life of being a math teacher. Number one, "Thou shalt recognize that some students fear and dislike math and be compassionate." And then there's a long list that's basically different ways to encourage the math teacher to keep patiently explaining over and over in different ways things until your students understand them. And then, at the end of that list, there's the rather mournful number 10, "Though they may at times seem few, thou shall count thy blessings." Then, of course, as Peaches & Herb remind us, there are The Ten Commandments of Love.
《数学老师十诫》——这其实揭示了很多数学老师的内心世界。第一条：“你应当意识到有些学生害怕并讨厌数学，要对他们抱有同情心。”然后是一长串清单，基本都是鼓励数学老师保持耐心，用不同的方式反复讲解，直到学生理解为止。清单最后是略带忧伤的第十条：“尽管有时看起来收获甚微，你也要数算你的恩典。”当然，正如“桃子与香草”合唱团提醒我们的，还有《爱情十诫》。
[MUSIC - "THE TEN COMMANDMENTS OF LOVE" BY PEACHES & HERB]
[音乐 - “爱情十诫” - 桃子与香草合唱团]
I think there's so many different versions of the Ten Commandments because 10 commandments are such a perfect way to get across an idea. There's 10 of them, you know, so it's enough that you feel like you're getting a comprehensive view. And yet at the same time, it's just 10, right? 10-- manageable. Not too overwhelming. Sure, I could do 10. 10? Sure.
我想之所以会有这么多版本的十诫，是因为十条诫命是传达一个理念的绝佳方式。一共有十条，你懂的，这足以让你感到获得了一个全面的视角。与此同时，又仅仅只有十条，对吧？十条——易于管理。不会太让人不知所措。当然，我能遵守十条。十条？没问题。
And you know, the Biblical commandments have one important thing that all these imitator commandments don't. And that is they're about much more basic stuff-- you know, primal stuff that's in our lives-- honoring parents, and murder, and lying, and wanting things we don't have. It doesn't get bigger than that.
而且你知道，圣经中的诫命有一点重要之处，是所有这些模仿版所不具备的。那就是它们关乎的内容基础得多——你知道，是我们生活中最根本的东西——孝敬父母、谋杀、说谎以及贪恋我们没有的东西。没有比这更宏大的主题了。
And we thought, we just had Easter and Passover. Let's find stories where people are grappling with these old, primal rules for life. With that in mind, we're devoting today's program to the Ten Commandments, the real ones. From WBEZ Chicago, it's "This American Life." I'm Ira Glass. Today's show-- The Ten Commandments. Stay with us.
我们想，刚好度过了复活节和逾越节。让我们去寻找一些人们正在努力践行这些古老、根本的生活准则的故事。带着这个想法，我们今天的节目将专门讨论十诫，也就是真正的那十诫。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——《十诫》。请继续收听。
Now different denominations attach different numbering schemes to the commandments, to which commandment goes with which number, though the commandments are always the same. But however you count them, the first two or three commandments, they cover the same ground. They're all about acknowledging God. "I'm the Lord your God. You shall have no other gods before me. You shall not carve idols and bow down to them and worship them, for I, the Lord your God, am a jealous god. You shall not take the name of the Lord your God in vain."
不同的教派对诫命有不同的编号方案，关于哪条诫命对应哪个数字，尽管诫命的内容总是一样的。但无论你怎么数，前两三条诫命涵盖的领域都是一样的。它们全都是关于承认上帝。“我是耶和华你的神。除了我以外，你不可有别神。你不可雕刻偶像，也不可跪拜、侍奉它们，因为我耶和华你的神是忌邪的神。你不可妄称耶和华你神的名。”
These commandments in particular are ones that Shalom Auslander tried to understand and obey as a boy going to religious school, a yeshiva-- a school where they were drilled in all of the Bible's commandments by teachers who could be pretty intimidating. Some more than others. Here's Shalom.
这些诫命尤其让沙洛姆·奥斯兰德在孩提时代就读宗教学校（犹太经学院）时努力去理解和遵守——那是一所由非常威严的老师向他们灌输圣经所有诫命的学校。有些老师比其他老师更可怕。下面请听沙洛姆的故事。
Eli said that his big brother said that Rabbi Breyer once broke a student's nose by slapping the student's face. Dov said that his big brother said that Rabbi Breyer had once broken a student's arm when he was dragging a student from the room for talking during prayers. Rabbi Breyer was the scariest rabbi in the whole yeshiva.
伊莱说他哥哥讲过，布雷耶尔拉比曾扇过一个学生的耳光，打断了他的鼻梁。多夫说他哥哥讲过，布雷耶尔拉比曾把一个学生从教室拖出去时弄断了他的胳膊，因为那个学生在祈祷时说话。布雷耶尔拉比是整个学校里最可怕的老师。
He was a stocky man, wide as the doorway, with a long rough beard and thick, angry. Hands. And everyone trembled that first day of third grade when he stomped heavily into the classroom, wrote his name on the blackboard, and shouted at Akiva for slouching in his seat. Nobody spoke during class. Nobody doodled in the margins of their prayer books. And when, at the end of the first test at the end of the first week Rabbi Breyer shouted, "Pencils down!" it was as if the commandment had come from God himself.
他是一个矮壮的人，像门框一样宽，留着长而粗糙的胡须，长着一双愤怒的、粗壮的手。三年级开学第一天，当他沉重地跺着脚走进教室，在黑板上写下自己的名字，并对因在座位上懒散坐着的阿基瓦大吼时，每个人都颤抖了。上课时没人说话。没人会在祈祷书的页边涂鸦。当第一周结束后的第一次考试结束时，布雷耶尔拉比大喊：“放下笔！”那感觉就像是诫命直接来自上帝本人。
At recess, we stood huddled together on the concrete slab beside the door, afraid to play, worried that Breyer was somewhere watching. Avi and Eli started flipping baseball cards. Flipping cards is considered gambling, which is forbidden. So we were supposed to return the cards to each other at the end of recess. Nobody ever did.
课间休息时，我们蜷缩在门边的水泥板上，不敢玩耍，担心布雷耶尔会在某处盯着。阿维和伊莱开始翻棒球卡。翻牌被认为是赌博，是禁止的。所以我们本应在课间结束时把卡片归还给对方。但从没人这么做过。
Eli won a large stack of cards from Avi, and I flipped Eli next. I lost an old Willie Randolph and frayed Lou Piniella, but I won a mint Carl Yastrzemski, whom I was pretty sure was Jewish. I'd been trying to win him for months.
伊莱赢了阿维一大摞卡片，接下来轮到我挑战伊莱。我输掉了一张旧的威利·兰道夫和一张磨损的卢·皮尼拉，但我赢了一张全新的卡尔·亚斯特泽姆斯基，我确信他是犹太人。我已经努力想赢到这张卡好几个月了。
The bell rang, and everyone headed glumly back to class where we sat quietly at our desks, waiting for Rabbi Breyer to return. I took out my Carl Yastrzemski, turned it over, and carefully wrote my name across the back. I didn't want to lose him and didn't plan on flipping him.
上课铃响了，大家都闷闷不乐地回到教室，静静地坐在课桌前，等着布雷耶尔拉比回来。我拿出我的卡尔·亚斯特泽姆斯基卡，翻到背面，小心翼翼地写上我的名字。我不想丢掉它，也没打算拿它去翻牌。
"Name of the Creator!" Rabbi Breyer shouted. I jumped and turned to find him standing beside me, his face red, his furious finger pointing at the baseball card on my desk. "Name of the Creator!" he shouted again. He grabbed the card from my desk.
“创造者的名！”布雷耶尔拉比吼道。我吓了一跳，转过身发现他站在我身边，脸涨得通红，他愤怒的手指正指着我桌上的棒球卡。“创造者的名！”他又吼了一遍。他从我桌上抓走了卡片。
Name of the Creator? I was confused. Yaz?
创造者的名？我很困惑。亚兹（Yaz）？
Rabbi Breyer slapped my hand, grabbed me by the ear, and led me to the head of the classroom. He held Yastrzemski over his head and shook him. "This," he declared loudly, "must never be thrown away. It must never touch the ground. It must never be covered." Then Rabbi Breyer waved the card in my face and told me that my name was the same name as God's. And I must never write it again.
布雷耶尔拉比打了我的手一下，揪住我的耳朵，把我拉到教室前面。他把亚斯特泽姆斯基卡举过头顶晃了晃。“这张，”他大声宣布，“绝不能被丢弃。绝不能触碰地面。绝不能被遮盖。”然后布雷耶尔拉比把卡片在我面前挥动，告诉我我的名字和上帝的名字是一样的。我绝不能再写它了。
The Jewish God has 72 names. And even though I was only eight years old, I already knew a lot of them. There was Adonai. There was Yahweh. There was Elohim. There was He Who is Full of Mercy, He Who is Quick to Anger, the Holy Spirit, the Divine Presence, the Rock, the Savior. And now, somewhere near the bottom of the list, there was Shalom-- peace-- my name.
犹太教的上帝有72个名字。尽管我只有八岁，但我已经知道很多了。有“阿多奈”（Adonai），有“雅威”（Yahweh），有“伊洛希姆”（Elohim）。有“满怀怜悯者”、“易怒者”、“圣灵”、“神圣临在”、“磐石”、“救主”。现在，在名单的底部附近，还有“沙洛姆”（Shalom）——和平——我的名字。
Rabbi Breyer handed me the baseball card, and told me to take it to the prayer hall upstairs and immediately put it in the Shaimos Box. Shaimos means "names," and it was the place where any old or unusable names of God are left to be discarded-- pages from prayer books, crumbling Talmuds, old Torah scrolls, and-- from now on-- anything I wrote my name on. When the box was filled, the rabbis would take it outside, dig a hole, and bury the pages in the ground.
布雷耶尔拉比把棒球卡交给我，叫我把它带到楼上的祈祷大厅，立刻放进“圣名盒”（Shaimos Box）。Shaimos的意思是“名字”，它是用来丢弃任何旧的或无法使用的上帝之名的地方——祈祷书的页面、残破的塔木德、旧的托拉经卷，以及——从现在起——任何写有我名字的东西。当盒子装满后，拉比们会把它带到外面，挖个坑，把这些书页埋在土里。
From now on, Rabbi Breyer said, when writing my name, I was to replace the last Hebrew letter, the M sound, with a simple apostrophe. I was no longer Shalom. I was Shalo'. I headed upstairs with a sigh.
布雷耶尔拉比说，从今往后，当我写自己的名字时，必须把最后一个希伯来字母（即M音）换成一个撇号。我不再是Shalom。我是Shalo'。我叹着气走向楼上。
Life with God's name was more difficult than I imagined. I was annoyed with God for being so selfish with them all. He had 71 other names. I couldn't see why he'd mind so much if I used just one.
顶着上帝的名字生活比我想象中更艰难。我对上帝对自己的名字如此自私感到恼火。他有71个别的名字。我不明白为什么他非得介意我只用其中一个。
I didn't want to tell God how to do his job, but I wondered if maybe there weren't bigger things for him to be worrying about than who was using one of his six dozen names without permission. Isn't this, I wondered, what led to holocausts?
我不想教上帝怎么做他的工作，但我怀疑他是否有比操心谁在未经允许下使用他的那六打名字中一个更大的事情要做。我想，大屠杀不就是由这类事引起的吗？
The Shaimos Box in the prayer hall filled quickly-- my homework, my test papers, my "what I did this summer," even my Highlights for Children-- and buried at the bottom of the box, a pair of underpants my mother had written my name on with permanent marker. It seemed I couldn't go an hour without making something holy.
祈祷大厅里的圣名盒很快就满了——我的作业、我的考卷、我的“暑假趣事”，甚至我的《儿童精华》杂志——盒子底部还埋着一条我妈妈用永久性记号笔写上我名字的内裤。似乎我一小时不把什么东西变得“神圣”就没法过。
And I wasn't the only one. Every morning, my mother wrote my name on my lunch bag-- the name of God in bright red magic marker, with a quickly drawn smiley face just below it. And every afternoon, Rabbi Breyer would grab my lunch bag, shout, "Name of the Creator!" dump the food out onto my desk, and send me upstairs to the Shaimos Box with my suddenly sacred lunch bag.
而且不只是我。每天早上，我妈妈都在我的午餐袋上写上我的名字——用鲜红色的记号笔写下的上帝之名，下面还画了个笑脸。每天下午，布雷耶尔拉比都会抓过我的午餐袋，吼着：“创造者的名！”把食物倒在我的桌上，然后让我拿着我那个突然变得神圣的午餐袋去楼上的圣名盒。
It didn't end with writing. I was standing at the urinal one day when Avi came in. "Hey, Shalom," he said.
这还没完。有一天我正在小便池前，阿维进来了。“嘿，沙洛姆，”他说。
"Name of the Creator!" Rabbi Breyer shouted from inside the nearby stall. "Name of the Creator!" We heard him fumbling with his pants and ran back to class. Later, as we sat with our heads down as punishment, Rabbi Breyer explained that speaking God's name in the bathroom was also forbidden.
“创造者的名！”布雷耶尔拉比在附近的隔间里吼道。“创造者的名！”我们听到他在里面摆弄裤子的声音，赶紧跑回教室。后来，当我们因惩罚而低头坐着时，布雷耶尔拉比解释说，在厕所里说上帝的名字也是被禁止的。
And then, a few weeks later, it suddenly all clicked. I began spelling my name with an apostrophe without even thinking. My mother stopped writing my name on my lunch bag. And my friends stopped saying hello to me in the bathroom.
然后，几周后，突然一切都通了。我开始不假思索地用撇号拼写自己的名字。我妈妈不再在我的午餐袋上写我的名字。我的朋友们也不再在厕所里跟我打招呼了。
It had been a hassle at the beginning, but now the whole God thing was growing on me. My classmates were named after rabbis and forefathers. Abraham? Isaac? Jacob? Please. I was named after God.
起初这很麻烦，但现在，整个上帝的事情开始让我着迷。我的同学是以拉比和先祖的名字命名的。亚伯拉罕？以撒？雅各？拜托。我可是以神之名命名的。
So I was surprised a few days later when I heard Rabbi Breyer in the middle of an exam on the first chapter of Genesis shout, "Name of the Creator!" I turned around, expecting to see him standing beside me. But he was on the far side of the classroom, standing behind Shlomo's desk, pointing a furious finger at Shlomo's test paper. "Name of the Creator!" he shouted again. And he slapped Shlomo's hand, grabbed him by the ear, and dragged him to the front of the class.
所以几天后，当我在创世记第一章的考试中听到布雷耶尔拉比吼道“创造者的名！”时，我很惊讶。我转过身，以为会看到他站在我身边。但他站在教室的另一侧，站在什洛莫（Shlomo）的课桌后面，愤怒的手指指着什洛莫的试卷。“创造者的名！”他又吼了一遍。他打了什洛莫的手，揪住他的耳朵，把他拖到教室前面。
Shlomo isn't technically a name of God, but it means His shalom, His peace. And for some reason, that day, Rabbi Breyer decided that was close enough. But instead of feeling relieved that someone else in our classroom would share the burden of a holy name, I was disappointed. It was a pain in the ass being named God. But it was my pain. And it was my ass.
什洛莫严格来说不算上帝的名字，但它意味着“他的平安”（His Shalom）。出于某种原因，那天，布雷耶尔拉比认为这已经足够接近了。但我并没有因为教室里还有别人分担这个神圣名字的负担而感到宽慰，反而感到失望。当“上帝”真是件烦人的事。但那是我的烦恼。而且那是我的名字。
Rabbi Breyer handed Shlomo his test paper and told me to take him upstairs to show him where the Shaimos Box was. I still didn't quite understand God's reasoning behind the third commandment of, "Thou shall not use my name in vain," but I suddenly had a pretty good idea of the reason behind the first, "Thou shall have no other gods besides me." It's one thing to be the only God. It's quite another, lesser thing to be one of two.
布雷耶尔拉比把试卷交给什洛莫，让我带他上楼去看看圣名盒在哪里。我仍然不太理解上帝关于第三条诫命“不可妄称我名”背后的理由，但我突然明白了第一条诫命“除了我以外，你不可有别神”背后的原因。当唯一的上帝是一回事，而成为两个上帝之一则是另一回事，而且是更卑微的事。
I headed upstairs with Shlomo two steps behind me. I wanted to push him down the stairs. I wanted to shove him out the window. As we walked toward the prayer hall, I remembered that Rabbi Breyer told us that Moses had killed an Egyptian by uttering the name of God.
我领着什洛莫往楼上走，他跟在我身后两步远的地方。我想把他推下楼梯。我想把他推窗外。当我们走向祈祷大厅时，我记起布雷耶尔拉比曾告诉我们，摩西是通过念出上帝的名字杀死了埃及人。
Shlomo pushed his way in front of me and hurried to the Shaimos Box. "Adonai," I whispered. Nothing. "Yahweh," I said. Nothing. I couldn't bear to watch him violating my Shaimos Box, so I turned and headed back to class, Shlomo running behind me, trying to keep up, using my name in vain, and calling, "Shalom, Shalom, wait up," as I squeezed my eyes shut and whispered, one last time, "Elohim." Nothing.
什洛莫挤到我前面，冲向圣名盒。“阿多奈，”我低语道。没反应。“雅威，”我说。没反应。我无法忍受看着他亵渎我的圣名盒，于是转过身走回教室，什洛莫在后面追着我，试图跟上，还妄称我的名字叫着：“沙洛姆，沙洛姆，等一下。”我闭紧双眼，最后一次低语道：“伊洛希姆。”没反应。
Shalom Auslander. He has a book of short stories called Beware of God and the memoir, Foreskins Lament.
沙洛姆·奥斯兰德。他有一本短篇小说集《当心上帝》，还有回忆录《包皮的挽歌》。
This brings us to the fourth commandment, "Remember the Sabbath day and keep it holy. Six days will you labor, but the seventh is a day of rest dedicated to the Lord your God."
这就引出了第四条诫命，“当纪念安息日，守为圣日。六日你要劳碌作工，但第七日是向耶和华你神当守的安息日。”
Good morning, everyone.
大家早上好。
Good morning.
早上好。
We're glad to have everyone here today.
我们很高兴大家今天能来到这里。
It is awesome to see you tonight. Thank you for coming to worship with us. The ushers are going to come forward now.
很高兴今晚见到大家。谢谢你们前来与我们一起敬拜。执事们现在请上台。
I'm going to be reading from the 48th division of Psalms. "Great is the Lord, and greatly to be praised. In the city of our God--"
我将诵读诗篇第48章。“耶和华本为大，该受大赞美，在我们神的城中……”
We also begin with words of blessing at the bottom of page 104.
我们也从第104页底部的祝福语开始。
[SPEAKING HEBREW]
[希伯来语]
[SPEAKING LATIN]
[拉丁语]
Here are six congregations in six different cities, remembering the Sabbath and trying to keep it holy.
这里有来自六个不同城市的六个会众，他们都在纪念安息日，并努力将其守为圣日。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语]
Lord, we pray for our sick and shut in everywhere, Lord. There are sick among us, Lord Jesus, that need you. Lord, we pray for the homeless on today. The men, the women--
主啊，我们为你各地受苦和禁足的人祈祷。主啊，我们中间有病人，主耶稣，他们需要你。主啊，我们今天为无家可归者祈祷。男人、女人——
United now in faith, we pray. May the Lord look with kindness upon all efforts to uphold the dignity of marriage and of family life, we pray to the Lord.
现在我们团结在信仰中祈祷。愿主仁慈地看待所有维护婚姻和家庭生活尊严的努力，我们求主垂听。
Lord, hear our prayer.
主啊，求你听我们的祷告。
We pray, especially, for the Neely family. We pray for the loss in the Golumbiski family on the loss of a cousin.
我们特别为尼利一家祈祷。我们为戈伦比斯基一家失去一位表亲而祈祷。
And here, all of us, can learn something from an ancient text which seems so irrelevant. When someone has, for whatever reason, had to separate themselves from society, the priest has to get involved, and help this person get back into the community.
在这里，我们所有人都可以从一段似乎无关紧要的古老经文中学习。当某人因故不得不与社会隔离时，祭司必须介入，帮助此人回归社区。
People claim nowadays that they are the first one who are asking for the womens' right. Islam, about 15 centuries ago, said, all people, you must consider the rights of your wives. Be kind and nice to them. Feel Allah in your wives, and be good to them. Oh, Allah, be my witness.
现在有人声称他们是第一批要求女性权利的人。伊斯兰教在约15个世纪前就说过，所有人，你们必须考虑妻子的权利。对她们仁慈友善。在你们的妻子身上感受到真主，并善待她们。噢，真主，请做我的见证。
Do I have a witness? We are the bride of Christ! Why? Because Christ died for us. He is married to us. And we need to understand what marriage means. You can't be married and cheating. And there are far to many of us cheating on Jesus. Nobody comes before Jesus.
我有见证人吗？我们是基督的新娘！为什么？因为基督为我们而死。他与我们结合。我们需要理解婚姻的意义。你不能在已婚的同时出轨。我们中有太多人背叛了耶稣。没有人能排在耶稣之前。
Turn to our hymnals on page 154, All Hail the Power of Jesus' Name. We'll all stand.
翻到赞美诗第154页，《万福尊名歌》（All Hail the Power of Jesus' Name）。全体起立。
Amen. Amen. Thank you all for coming. And you're all welcome to stay.
阿们。阿们。谢谢大家的到来。欢迎留下。
(SINGING) Speak, oh Lord, as we come to you to receive the fruit of your holy word.
（歌唱）主啊，请发言，当我们来到你面前领受你圣道的果实。
This is the Bent Tree Bible Fellowship in Carrollton, Texas. And before that, the Northwest Venice United Methodist Church in Corunna, Michigan, Faith Tabernacle Baptist Church in Chicago, the Muslim Community Association mosque in Ann Arbor, Michigan, Temple Rodef Shalom in Falls Church, Virginia, and Our Lady of Angels Monastery in Hanceville, Alabama. We recorded them in 2007, when we first broadcast today's show.
这是德克萨斯州卡罗尔顿的本特树圣经团契。在此之前是密歇根州科鲁纳的西北威尼斯联合卫理公会、芝加哥的信仰会幕浸信会、密歇根州安阿伯的穆斯林社区协会清真寺、弗吉尼亚州福尔斯彻奇的罗德夫沙洛姆会堂，以及阿拉巴马州汉斯维尔的天使圣母修道院。我们是在2007年首次播出今天的节目时录制他们的。
If you're just tuning in, we are devoting our show today to the Ten Commandments, and we are at commandment number five right now, "Honor your father and your mother." When he was 11, in Charleston, South Carolina, Jack Hitt and his friends back then formed a little club where they would hang out at this one backyard that was all overgrown and which they thought of at the time as a jungle. It had a big brick wall along one side. And they started doing things that did not honor their fathers and their mothers.
如果你刚刚收听，我们今天专门讨论十诫，现在我们进行到第五条诫命，“孝敬父母。”当杰克·希特在南卡罗来纳州查尔斯顿11岁时，他和朋友们组建了一个小俱乐部，经常在一个杂草丛生的后院里闲逛，那时他们认为那是片丛林。院子的一侧有一堵巨大的砖墙。他们开始做一些不孝敬父母的事情。
Anyway, we had declared it to be our land. We were squatters. And so we started painting things on the wall. And one of us painted a naked woman. And one of us wrote his name and then "loves" and then, you know, the girl he had a thing for at that time. And that's how he got caught because he wrote his name on the wall. And then I wrote all these bad words. I just wrote every bad word I could think of.
总之，我们宣布那片土地属于我们。我们是占屋者。于是我们开始在墙上画画。其中一个画了一个裸女。另一个写下自己的名字，然后写上“爱”，接着是你懂的，他当时暗恋的女孩的名字。这就是他被抓的原因，因为他在墙上写了自己的名字。然后我写了所有我能想到的坏话。
And so I came home one day, and the police came to my house and told my parents-- or called my father at work or something. And anyway, he came home early from work. And he sat me down in his big study and said, you know, I understand you painted some words on a wall? And I was like, oh, my god. I just burst into tears. You know? I was just beyond control.
有一天我回家时，警察来到我家，告诉了我的父母——或者是打电话给我正在上班的父亲。总之，他早早地从单位回到家。他让我坐在他的大书房里，说，听说你在墙上画了一些词？我当时就，天哪。我直接泪崩了。你知道吗？我彻底失控了。
My father never cursed, at least not in front of us. And he was very strict about language. And so he asked me what words I painted on the wall. And I think I choked out, "H-E-double hockey sticks," or something. And you know, he kind of looked down, hmm. "Very grave, indeed. Anything else?"
我父亲从不骂人，至少不在我们面前。他对语言非常严苛。于是他问我在墙上画了什么词。我想我结结巴巴地说出了“H-E-double hockey sticks”（指Hell/地狱）之类的。他低头看了一眼，嗯。“非常严重啊。还有别的吗？”
I was like, yeah. That was just the warm up. And so then I said, you know, I painted the other words. I can't say them. I can't say them. And then he said, oh. Well, tell me what it started with. You know, he was going to get it out of me.
我说，有。那只是热身。于是我说，我还画了其他的词。我没法说出来。我真的说不出口。然后他说，哦。那告诉我第一个字是什么。你知道，他一定要从我嘴里撬出来。
So I coughed up the letter S. And he was just-- his eyes blazed. And he bowed his head. Oh, my god. "Anything else?" And I could not be contained. I was wailing around on the sofa. I said, there's only one word left, and yeah, I painted it. And he was just-- I think he was actually thunderstruck.
于是我吐出了字母S。他当时——他的眼睛冒火。他低下头。天哪。“还有别的吗？”我彻底崩溃了。我在沙发上嚎啕大哭。我说，只剩最后一个词了，没错，我也画了。他当时——我想他是真的被惊呆了。
And then he sat there in silence for a few minutes. And then he looked up at me, and he said-- now, you have to understand, my father comes from the rural area, marries the southern belle in Charleston, South Carolina. So marriage of two kinds of families, you know, in the south.
然后他沉默了几分钟。他抬起头看着我，说——现在你要理解，我父亲来自农村，娶了查尔斯顿南部的大家闺秀。所以那是两种家庭在南部的结合。
And he said, son, I've worked all my life to make sure that when you or your sisters or your brother walk down the street, people say, there goes a Hitt. They're good people. I don't think anything that anybody in this family has done has damaged that reputation as much as you have today.
他说，儿子，我这一辈子都在努力工作，确保当你或者你的姐妹们或是哥哥走在街上时，人们会说，希特家的人来了，他们是好人家。我不认为家里任何人做过的事能像你今天这样损害家族声誉。
And he said, that is your punishment. You may go now. You know, I was 11.
然后他说，这就是你的惩罚。你可以走了。你懂的，那时我才11岁。
Wow.
哇。
I was just-- I was floored, you know? I asked him, I think, to spank me. Because, of course, part of me wanted an explosion that would end it. But he said, when he dismissed me from the room-- he said, you know, this has been your punishment. And then, of course, you know, a couple of months later, he dies. And that's one of my last memories-- is him telling me that.
我当时就——我被彻底击垮了，你知道吗？我甚至想让他打我一顿。因为我内心深处希望有一场爆发来结束这一切。但他只是让我离开房间——他说，你知道，这就是你的惩罚了。后来，当然，几个月后，他就去世了。那是我的最后记忆之一——就是他对我说的那些话。
Do you think he was being sincere?
你觉得他是真心的吗？
Well, I'll tell you-- years later, we had a little family reunion. I might have been 20. I mean, I was in college. And all my siblings got together. And they were all married at this point. And we dismissed all the in-laws to go see the movies. And the five of us stayed out really late talking.
好吧，告诉你——几年后，我们有个小家庭聚会。我那时可能20岁。我的意思是，我正在上大学。我所有的兄弟姐妹都聚在了一起。他们那时都已经结婚了。我们让配偶们去看电影了。我们五个人待到很晚一直在聊天。
And I don't think we'd ever really talked about our father in any deep way since he had died. And I started telling that story, and I had never told that story, because I was ashamed of it. It was the black mark on the family, that I had done this, right?
我想自从父亲去世后，我们从来没有深入谈论过他。我开始讲那个故事，我以前从没讲过，因为我对此感到羞愧。那是我们家的污点，我做了那种事，对吧？
And I couldn't bring to-- I'd never told anybody that story. And I started telling that story. And all my sisters start wailing with laughter. And then they all start telling the story that-- what they had done that had prompted, essentially, the exact same speech.
我从没对任何人讲过那个故事。我开始讲述时，我所有的姐妹们都笑得前仰后合。然后她们开始讲她们自己做的事，那些事情基本上也引出了他一模一样的演讲。
Like, one of them had been caught shoplifting in Atlanta, and he had to fly there and get her. You know? And that was just, you know, a terrible story. I'd never heard that one before you. And I thought, hoo-wee, well, you know, painting a few bad words on a wall, that's nothing compared to shoplifting in Atlanta.
比如，其中一个在亚特兰大因商店行窃被抓，他不得不飞过去接她。你知道吗？那是个很糟糕的故事。在那之前我从没听说过。我想，哇哦，你看，在墙上画几个坏词，跟在亚特兰大行窃比起来根本不算什么。
And was this the first time that everybody else was realizing that he had said the speech to them too? Or were you the only one who didn't know?
这是其他人第一次意识到他也对他们说过同样的演讲吗？还是你是唯一一个不知道的人？
I think I was the only one who didn't know. I mean, they're much older than I am. I'm a mistake, right? So my oldest sister is 16 years older than I am. So I think what was kind of moving about that whole encounter is that all of them had long ago forgotten their particular crime that had prompted Daddy to give them the big reputation speech.
我想我是唯一一个不知道的人。他们比我大得多。我是个意外，对吧？我大姐比我大16岁。所以我认为那次交谈感人之处在于，他们早就不记得导致爸爸给他们做那次重大声誉演讲的具体罪行了。
But you know, when I brought it up, it suddenly-- for all of them, that all flooded back. I mean, it just created this great little moment where we all suddenly realized we were, you know-- the whole family was just so defined by my father's rather Baptist sense of morality.
但你知道，当我提起时，突然间——对他们所有人来说，那一切都涌现了出来。我的意思是，这创造了一个很棒的小瞬间，我们突然意识到我们——整个家庭都被我父亲那种浸信会式的道德观定义了。
Jack Hitt is the co-host of the podcast "Uncivil."
杰克·希特是播客《Uncivil》的联合主持人。
Well, the sixth commandment seems like it could not be more straightforward. "Thou shalt not kill." But of course, even this is one that is not always so simple to know how to obey. Army Reserve Chaplain Lieutenant Colonel Lyn Brown is back in this country from Iraq, where he has served two tours.
好吧，第六条诫命似乎再直白不过了。“不可杀人。”但当然，即使是这一条，也并不总是一看就知道该如何遵守。美国陆军预备役牧师林·布朗中校刚从伊拉克回国，他在那里服役了两个任期。
When he was in Iraq, he would run services for his unit once a week. But most of his ministry was just talking to guys one on one. The main issue they have, he says, is about missing their families. But often they talk to him about killing. He spoke with Alex Blumberg.
他在伊拉克时，每周为他的部队举行一次礼拜。但他大部分的牧师工作是与士兵一对一地谈话。他说，他们面临的主要问题是思念家人。但他们也经常和他谈论杀戮。他接受了亚历克斯·布伦伯格的采访。
I did meet with one soldier on several occasions to just work through the commandment. This young man had actually, along with another soldier, gone forward when the vehicle in front of them had been blown up to hold the hand of a soldier who was not going to survive.
我确实多次会见了一名士兵，专门探讨这条诫命。这个年轻人实际上和另一名士兵一起，在前方车辆被炸毁后冲上前去，握住了一个活不下来的士兵的手。
Somebody had told me that he was having a tough time. And so I went over to him, and I just said, you know, what are you thinking? And he said, I never thought about the killing that would be going on. You know, when you're firing at a target to practice, you think of those things as targets, not as people.
有人告诉我他过得很艰难。于是我走过去，对他简单地说，你知道，你在想什么？他说，我从没想过会发生杀戮。你知道，当你练习向目标射击时，你把那些看作目标，而不是人。
And for him to be there and to see that he had some buddies that were on the receiving end-- and he was just saying, the Ten Commandments in the Bible says, "Thou shalt not kill." And he says, I'm not certain I can go out and kill.
对他来说，身临其境并看到他的伙伴成了受害者——他只是说，圣经里的十诫说，“不可杀人。”他说，我不确定我是否能去杀人。
Was his concern with it, like, God wouldn't forgive him, or that it was wrong?
他的担忧是因为，比如上帝不会原谅他，还是觉得那是不对的？
Well, it was that God wouldn't approve of him doing that.
嗯，是担心上帝不会批准他那样做。
Right.
没错。
And he also brought up just, if you were to do it, who could he tell? Because, he said, I wouldn't want to tell my girlfriend about this. I wouldn't want to tell my children.
而且他还提到了，如果你真的做了，你能告诉谁？因为他说，我不想告诉女朋友，也不想告诉孩子们。
And that's why I went ahead and had a little Bible study with him. It was the kind of thing that I did meet with him on several occasions to find out what God had to say about war, and where did the commandment, "Thou shalt not kill,"-- where did that come in? But also to work through other instances where-- for example, in the New Testament, where Jesus meets an army officer who has a child who's dying, and he asks Jesus if he would heal his daughter.
这就是为什么我继续和他进行了一些圣经研究。我确实多次会见他，找出上帝对战争的看法，以及“不可杀人”这条诫命在其中处于什么位置。但也探讨了一些其他例子——例如，在新约中，耶稣遇到了一位军官，他的孩子快要死了，他请求耶稣医治他的女儿。
But the interesting thing I would point out is that Jesus never condemned the soldier for his job. Now, I also know that when King David wanted to build a temple that God said, no. He said, your son's going to do it because you're a man of blood. And so there's a lot of controversy, as you can imagine, as to trying to interpret what God was talking about there.
但我指出的有趣一点是，耶稣从未因军官的工作而谴责他。现在，我也知道当大卫王想建圣殿时，上帝说不。他说，你的儿子会建，因为你是流血的人。所以，你可以想象，关于试图解释上帝在那里所说的话，有很多争议。
And of course, that seems to reflect on, you know, even my role as a chaplain. You know, why am I wearing an Army uniform and trying to deal with people who are out to kill people?
当然，这似乎也反映在我作为牧师的角色上。你知道，为什么我穿着陆军制服，试图应付那些准备杀人的人？
Are there times that you feel that faith and the US military are sort of at odds?
有没有觉得信仰和美军有时是矛盾的？
Yes. You know, we preach the love of God and the fact that we ought to be at peace with each other. And the same time I'm wearing a uniform that says US Army on it. And I'm there to support them in their mission of winning a war. And that means taking lives.
有。你知道，我们宣讲上帝的爱以及我们要和平共处的事实。与此同时，我穿着一件写着美国陆军的制服。我在这里是为了支持他们赢得战争的使命。这意味着夺走生命。
So I do wrestle with that. I mean, there's times that you just kind of go, you know, God, can I resign here? Right? Can I get away from this? Rather than having to deal with the questioning that people have and often not having answers. I mean, I think that probably the biggest challenge that I ever had was I couldn't just say, just think this way, and you'll be fine. There were times that they were asking the same questions that I would be asking.
所以我确实为此挣扎。我的意思是，有时你只是会想，你知道，上帝，我可以辞职吗？对吧？我可以远离这一切吗？而不是必须处理人们提出的质疑，而且往往得不到答案。我的意思是，我认为我所面临的最大挑战是我不能只说，你只要这样想，你就没问题了。有时他们问的问题，也是我自己会问的问题。
Such as?
比如？
Well, should we be here? Should we be killing people?
嗯，我们该在这里吗？我们该杀人吗？
Do you think that you have a different understanding of this particular commandment, about the fifth commandment, "Thou shalt not kill?" Do you feel like you have a different understanding of it after serving in Iraq than, perhaps, somebody who didn't serve?
你觉得你在伊拉克服役后，对这条诫命，即第五条（按犹太教传统排序为第六条）“不可杀人”，是否有不同的理解？你是否觉得比那些没服役过的人有不同的理解？
I think I'm much more hesitant about having a definite opinion about who should die. Just seeing the brutality and the people who've got body parts missing or there's big holes. They died a violent death. And it's not pretty. And it just doesn't seem normal, which it isn't.
我想我对谁该死这种事更不敢下定论了。只要看到了残暴，看到了身体部位缺失的人，或者是巨大的伤口。他们死于暴力。这并不美好。这看起来也不正常，事实确实如此。
But also, even with the Iraqi culture, there were times that people just said-- well, whatever group it was they didn't agree with, they just said, kill them all. And I was going, uh, you know, these are people. And I didn't like that attitude.
但即使在伊拉克文化中，有时人们也会说——无论他们不同意哪个群体，他们只会说，把他们全杀了。我当时想，呃，你知道，他们是人。我不喜欢那种态度。
And then I was seeing it, even among the armed forces, that there was people that would just kind of say, well, we just need to kill them all, and then that'll take care of it. And I was going, whoa! Who nominated you to be God?
然后我看到了，即使在武装部队中，也有人只会说，嗯，我们只需要把他们全杀了，那样就解决了。我当时想，哇！谁提名你当上帝了？
You know, we all have a tendency to interpret the Ten Commandments in a way that's convenient for us. There's the interpretation of, "Thou shalt not murder," it shouldn't be a premeditated killing. It has nothing do with war. Those kinds of things.
你知道，我们都有以对自己有利的方式解释十诫的倾向。有种解释是，“不可谋杀”，那不应该是有预谋的杀戮。这与战争无关。诸如此类。
But it just makes me-- I'm looking at it as a principle that God says, you need to value life, and don't take it lightly. Just don't condemn people to death just because that's easy to do. You got to stop and think about it seriously. This is something that God, Himself, doesn't take lightly.
但这让我——我把它看作是一个上帝传达的原则，即你需要尊重生命，不要轻视它。不要仅仅因为这样做容易就判人死刑。你必须停下来认真思考。这是上帝本人都不敢轻视的事情。
Army Reserve Chaplain Lieutenant Colonel Lyn Brown talking with Alex Blumberg. Coming up-- adultery, thievery, lying, envy. No, it is not an afternoon of daytime TV. It is the last four commandments. We have one story for each of them. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
陆军预备役牧师林·布朗中校接受亚历克斯·布伦伯格采访。接下来——通奸、偷盗、说谎、嫉妒。不，这不是下午的电视节目。这是最后四条诫命。我们为每一条准备了一个故事。稍后在我们的节目继续时，从芝加哥公共广播电台为您播出。
It's "This American Life". I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, of course, we choose a theme, bringing you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show-- the Ten Commandments.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们都会选择一个主题，为您带来各种不同的故事。今天的节目——《十诫》。
We're doing one story for each of the commandments. The first few commandments, of course, about how to relate to God. Then there's one on relating to your parents. And the rest are all direct injunctions about how to act-- basically, a list of things that you are not supposed to do. We are at commandment number seven, "You shall not commit adultery."
我们为每条诫命准备了一个故事。前几条诫命当然是关于如何与上帝相处。然后是一条关于如何对待父母的。其余的都是关于如何行动的直接训诫——基本上是一份你不应该做的事情的清单。我们进行到了第七条诫命，“不可奸淫。”
And yes, we are at the commandment that is about sex. And while there is going to be nothing explicit in this next story, it does acknowledge the existence of sex. A little warning there.
没错，我们进行到了关于性的那条诫命。虽然下一个故事中不会有任何露骨的内容，但它确实承认了性的存在。小小提醒一下。
In 1976, in an interview with Playboy magazine, then presidential candidate Jimmy Carter admitted, kind of famously, that he had committed adultery in his heart many times, meaning, of course, that he had had lustful thoughts. There's this thing that Jesus says in the book of Matthew-- "Whoever looks at a woman lustfully has committed adultery in his heart." Dave Dickerson grew up going to an evangelical church in Tucson, Arizona. And he remembers hearing about what Carter said about committing adultery in his heart.
1976年，在接受《花花公子》杂志采访时，当时的总统候选人吉米·卡特以一种著名的方式承认，他在心里多次犯过通奸罪，意思当然是他有过淫念。耶稣在马太福音里说过这么一句话——“凡看见妇女就动淫念的，这人心里已经与她犯奸淫了。”戴夫·迪克森在亚利桑那州图森市的一家福音派教会长大。他记得听过关于卡特所说的在心里犯通奸罪的言论。
I was eight years old, and I knew just what he was talking about. He was just saying the same thing I had read in my Bible dozens of times.
那时我八岁，我很清楚他在说什么。他说的和我从圣经里读过几十遍的话是一样的。
As an evangelical Christian, I wanted desperately to please God. So for my entire adolescence and up into my 20s, I literally tried to avoid having lustful thoughts. I was taught this was possible. Paul says in Second Corinthians that we take every thought captive in the name of Jesus, which means that any spiritually healthy person ought to be able to control every thought in his head.
作为一名福音派基督徒，我非常渴望取悦上帝。所以我整个青春期一直到20多岁，我都确实在努力避免产生淫念。我被教导这是可能的。保罗在哥林多后书中说，我们要将人所有的心意夺回，使他都顺服基督，这意味着任何灵性健康的人都应该能够控制大脑中的每一个念头。
Of course, in practice this is even harder than it sounds. So for young evangelicals like me there's a whole sub-industry of sex advice columns and books with titles like, Every Man's Struggle or Taking Thoughts Captive. You find them in the "for men" section of any Christian bookstore.
当然，在实践中，这比听起来还要难。所以对于像我这样年轻的福音派教徒来说，有一个庞大的性建议专栏和书籍子产业，书名如《每个人的挣扎》或《将心意夺回》。你可以在任何基督教书店的“男士专用”区找到它们。
The first thing they always tell you is that sex is a beautiful gift from God, even though it's a gift they don't want you to touch or even think about because you're just going to ruin it with your filthy paws. Any physical pleasure, even pleasure you'd give yourself while alone, is completely forbidden. Then they tell you how to survive until marriage. They all run some variation on, you can't help the first glance, but you can prevent the second.
他们首先告诉你的总是：性是上帝给的珍贵礼物，尽管这礼物他们不想让你触碰甚至思考，因为你只会用你那肮脏的爪子毁掉它。任何身体上的快感，甚至是你独自一人时给自己的快感，都是完全禁止的。然后他们告诉你如何熬到结婚。他们都采用了某种变体，即：你无法阻止第一眼，但你可以阻止第二眼。
You can obey God with your eyes. They don't have to see everything around them. If an attractive girl walks by, they don't have to survey her body, but they must obey Jesus Christ.
你可以用眼睛顺服上帝。它们不必环顾四周看所有东西。如果一个有吸引力的女孩走过，你不必打量她的身体，但你必须顺服耶稣基督。
This is Josh Harris in the audio version of his book, Not Even a Hint, Guarding Your Heart Against Lust. It's full of practical tips.
这是乔希·哈里斯在他书的音频版《连暗示都没有，守护你的心抵挡情欲》中所说的话。书里充满了实用的建议。
I don't know about your house, but at our home, all kinds of sensuous and provocative clothing catalogs arrive in the mail uninvited. I've come to realize that I have to view even getting my mail as a battleground. Will I throw them away immediately or steal glances and flip through them for a quick thrill? If you're a guy with a similar struggle, ask your wife or mother to help you in this area by ridding your home of these unnecessary temptations.
我不知道你们家情况如何，但在我们家，各种诱人且挑逗性的服装目录会在没有邀请的情况下邮寄到家。我意识到，即使是取邮件也必须被视为战场。我是该立刻把它们扔掉，还是偷看一眼并翻阅它们寻求瞬间的刺激？如果你是一个有类似挣扎的男士，请寻求你的妻子或母亲在这一领域的帮助，清理掉你家中的这些不必要的诱惑。
Other tips-- these books tell you to watch TV with the remote in your hand so if a sexy beer commercial comes on or when the sports camera cuts to the cheerleaders, you can immediately jump to another channel. And be honest with yourself, when you watch ESPN2, aren't you hoping to see gymnastics? And guys need daily quiet time to read the Bible and pray for strength in the fight against temptation.
其他建议——这些书告诉你手里拿着遥控器看电视，如果出现性感的啤酒广告，或者体育镜头切换到拉拉队员时，你可以立刻换台。而且要对自己诚实，当你观看ESPN2时，难道不是希望看到体操比赛吗？男士们每天需要安静时间来阅读圣经并祈求力量以对抗诱惑。
I don't know why, but in my case, none of this ever worked. I wanted it to work, longed for it desperately. But every week or so, late at night, I'd give in. "M happened again," I would write in my journal, as if it weren't an action but an event, something that could just engulf you, like a flash flood or a car accident, something so terrible it could only be referred to in code.
我不知道为什么，但在我的例子中，这些都没用。我希望它有用，我极其渴望它有用。但每隔一周左右，深夜里，我就会屈服。“M又发生了，”我会在日记里写道，好像那不是一个动作而是一个事件，某种可以席卷你的东西，就像突如其来的洪水或车祸，某种太可怕了只能用暗语指代的东西。
I was an adulterer. That's what the Bible told me. And I struggled with the guilt of that every day.
我是一个通奸者。圣经就是这样告诉我的。我每天都在那种负罪感中挣扎。
After high school, I went to a huge state college in Tucson. And on warm days, I would walk across campus feeling like a monster because I believed that noticing a girl's body was the spiritual equivalent of something like sexual assault. I assumed all this was the same for all of us fundamentalist kids. At every all-guys prayer meeting I ever went to, someone was always asking for help with their thought life.
高中毕业后，我去了图森市一所大型公立大学。在温暖的日子里，我走在校园里觉得自己像个怪物，因为我相信注意到一个女孩的身体在精神上等同于性侵犯。我以为我们这些原教旨主义孩子都有同样的情况。在我去过的每一次纯男性祈祷会上，总有人在寻求关于他们思想生活的帮助。
But I'd never actually asked if anyone had quite the same problems I did. So I called my friend, Derek, a missionaries' kid who was my best friend from church back then.
但我从没真的问过是否有人和我面临同样的问题。所以我给我的朋友德里克打了电话，他是传教士的孩子，也是我当时教会里最好的朋友。
You're right. It wasn't your own obsession at all. I developed a technique of seeing girls as just floating heads. It was like, just learn you're just not going to look below the neck. Because it's like--
你是对的。那根本不是你个人的困扰。我开发了一种技术，把女孩们只看作漂浮的头颅。就像是，只要学会不往脖子以下看就行了。因为它就像——
Because there's only bad news there.
因为下面只有坏消息。
It did have this funny effect on-- I mean, I was a cartoonist for my college newspaper. And I didn't actually know how to draw girls really. I mean, you can see--
这对——我的意思是，我是大学校报的漫画家。我确实不知道怎么画女孩。我的意思是，你可以看到——
That's right.
没错。
You can see when I would draw a female figure, top to bottom, in a cartoon, there's an awkwardness to it because I didn't actually know what they looked like. And it's those kind of things that were kind of-- it's funny to look back and talk about them now, but it was all very dead serious back then.
你可以看到当我画女性人物，从头到脚，在漫画里时，有一种尴尬感，因为我实际上不知道她们长什么样。那些事情……现在回过头谈论它们很可笑，但在当时一切都非常严肃。
Oh, yeah. That's the other thing. I mean, it seems so trivial and silly, and yet it caused actual agony. You know, we felt depraved.
噢，是的。那也是另一回事。我的意思是，这看起来很琐碎愚蠢，却造成了实际的痛苦。你知道，我们感到堕落。
Yeah, and there's this terrible-- a real anger, a sense of unfairness at the media. Like, Coors Lite put up these billboards with women in swimsuits on them, and they were very well-designed swimsuits. And then there they would be, right? Like, right up in the sky. You know?
是的，而且有一种可怕的——对媒体真实的愤怒，一种不公平感。比如，Coors Lite啤酒在广告牌上挂着穿泳装的女性照片，那是设计得很巧妙的泳装。然后她们就这样存在了，对吧？就像是在天空中。你知道吗？
And so you just felt like the devil was just absolutely this very wily opponent. And it's just in your face all the time. And it's so frustrating if you're trying not to go out of your way to look for it, but then it seems like everybody's pushing it in your face.
所以你会觉得魔鬼绝对是个非常狡猾的对手。它一直都在你眼前。如果你试图不刻意去寻找它，却发现似乎每个人都在把它往你眼前推，这真令人沮丧。
Do you ever, you know, wish you could go back?
你有没有，你知道，希望你能回到过去？
Yeah. You know, it's funny you should ask that because I have actually had that imaginary conversation before. You see some time travel movie and fantasize like, wow, if I had a chance to go back, what would I tell that kid? And I think I would tell myself, you know what? You spend so much time straining over this one issue that you are avoiding, or overlooking, the whole rest of your spiritual journey.
是啊。你知道，问得好，因为我以前真的进行过那种想象中的对话。你看某部时间旅行电影，幻想着，哇，如果我有机会回到过去，我会告诉那个孩子什么？我想我会告诉自己，你知道吗？你花太多时间在这个单一问题上纠结，以至于你在逃避，或者忽视了你整个其余的精神旅程。
I wasted a lot of time. That was a lot of time wasted obsessing. And I think that's kind of what you found out yourself, too, right? Like, it just gets to a point where things crack instead of bending.
我浪费了太多时间。那是太多的时间浪费在执念上。我想这和你自己发现的情况差不多，对吧？就像，事情到了某一点会折断而不是弯曲。
He's right. They do crack. And for me, they cracked worse than for Derek.
他是对的。确实会折断。对我来说，折断得比德里克更严重。
I couldn't buy porn. That was obviously forbidden. I didn't have a girlfriend. I couldn't even watch MTV. So the only sexual experiences I'd had were the ones that happened by accident-- a woman bending over in a low-cut shirt, for instance.
我不能买色情刊物。那显然是禁止的。我没有女朋友。我甚至不能看MTV。所以我唯一有过的性经历就是偶然发生的——例如，一个女人弯腰穿着低胸衬衫。
And then at 22, I started finding myself walking slowly along campus, or in supermarkets, or the library, hoping to see another accidental glimpse of something. It took more and more of my time. My grades started to suffer. I was like a stalker, but a shy one, with incredibly low standards. Then after a couple unbearable months of this, I begged my pastor for help. He suggested Sex Addicts Anonymous.
然后在22岁时，我发现自己开始在校园里、超市或图书馆里缓慢行走，希望能偶然看到点什么。这占据了我越来越多的时间。我的成绩开始下降。我像个跟踪狂，但是个害羞的跟踪狂，标准极低。在经历了几个月令人无法忍受的日子后，我乞求牧师帮助。他建议参加“性瘾者互诫协会”。
At my first meeting, we all told our stories. There was a guy who'd spent thousands of dollars on prostitutes in a single long weekend. There was a woman who'd slept with a different guy almost every night for years. There was a huge tattooed biker who was so ashamed to be there that a friend led him in blindfolded. And then there was me, a 22-year-old virgin. When I told my story, there was an awkward silence. Even here, nobody understood my problem.
在第一次会议上，我们都讲述了自己的故事。有一个家伙在一个漫长的周末里花了几千美元找妓女。有一个女人多年来几乎每晚都和不同的男人睡。有一个巨大的文身骑手感到非常羞愧，以至于朋友蒙着他的眼睛带他进去。然后是我，一个22岁的处男。当我讲完故事时，出现了一阵尴尬的沉默。即使在这里，也没人理解我的问题。
A few days later, I went to a Christian counselor, expecting he'd just tell me to pray harder, look for answers in the scripture. I explained my problem, and he looked at me and frowned. And then he asked if I ever did the act, the one that I found so horrible I only referred to it in code. Trust me, he said. Let yourself do it. Give yourself permission, and see what happens.
几天后，我去找了一位基督教咨询师，期望他只会告诉我要更努力地祈祷，从经文中寻找答案。我解释了我的问题，他看着我皱起眉头。然后他问我是否真的做过那件事，那件我觉得太可怕以至于只能用暗语指代的事。相信我，他说。让自己做吧。给自己许可，看看会发生什么。
This was shocking, that a Christian would give me this kind of advice. That it's possible to obey too much, that you could lead yourself astray by following the Bible's rules. That very day I took home my first Playboy magazine. And that was that.
这太令人震惊了，一个基督徒竟然会给我这种建议。竟然会有过度顺服这种事，你可以因为遵循圣经的规则而误入歧途。就在那天，我带回了我的第一本《花花公子》。就这样。
After five minutes, I was no longer desperate to glimpse random women bending over the freezer cases at the grocery store. It felt like a miracle. It was so fast, so life changing, that it was like converting all over again.
五分钟后，我不再渴望在杂货店的冷冻柜前瞥见随机弯腰的女人了。感觉就像个奇迹。太快了，改变了人生，就像重新皈依了一样。
Dave Dickerson.
戴夫·迪克森。
Commandment number eight--
第八条诫命——
This is your Sprite. Here's a Coke for you.
这是你的雪碧。这是给你的可乐。
"You shall not steal."
“不可偷盗。”
Are you ready to order or you need more time? What can I get for you?
你准备好点餐了吗，还是需要更多时间？我能为您拿点什么？
I work as a waiter. I've been here since 1994. That's almost 13 years working in this place.
我是一名服务员。我从1994年就在这儿了。在这地方工作快13年了。
Hassan works the afternoon shift at a neighborhood restaurant.
哈桑在一家社区餐馆上下午班。
Well, people usually steal a lot of things. They steal different stuff. For example, they steal umbrellas from other customers.
好吧，人们通常偷很多东西。他们偷各种各样的东西。例如，他们从其他顾客那里偷雨伞。
Really?
真的吗？
Oh, yeah. I saw him with my eyes. And the guy was a lawyer. He stole-- he had a broken umbrella. And in the umbrella box there was a good umbrella. He took it away with him.
哦，是的。我亲眼看到的。那家伙是个律师。他偷了——他有一把破雨伞。在雨伞盒里有一把好的。他就把它带走了。
Do you think it might have been a mistake?
你觉得那可能是个误会吗？
I don't think so. Lawyers, they don't make mistake. There was two couples. One of the couples, the wife, she used to sit on the right side of the corner.
我不这么认为。律师，他们不会犯错。当时有两对夫妇。其中一对夫妇的妻子，她总是坐在角落的右侧。
She'd sit in this booth.
她坐在那个卡座里。
Yeah, this one. She used to take salt and pepper from the tables. No matter what we did, no matter what we said, no matter what we act, she never changed. She always took it. I believe that she took at least two dozens during the two-years period.
是的，就那个。她过去常从桌子上拿走盐瓶和胡椒瓶。无论我们怎么做，无论我们说什么，无论我们怎么表现，她从不改变。她总是拿。我相信在两年的时间里她至少拿走了两打。
Two dozen?
两打？
Yes.
是的。
They stole two dozen salt and pepper shakers.
他们偷了两打盐瓶和胡椒瓶。
Yeah, total during the two-years period. Like, if one second I missed-- gone.
是的，两年里的总数。只要我错开一秒——就没了。
And she was a regular customer?
她是常客吗？
Oh, yeah. Regular customer. And I believe she was doing it everywhere, wherever she goes.
哦，是的。常客。而且我相信她走到哪儿都这么干。
Well, what I don't understand is what would she do with two dozen salt and pepper shakers?
嗯，我不明白她要两打盐瓶和胡椒瓶干什么？
I don't know. I don't know. That I want to know, too.
我不知道。我不知道。我也想知道这个。
Do you think--
你觉得——
Maybe she has a store?
也许她有个店？
He says it doesn't happen often, the stealing. But there is a pattern he's noticed. When a woman walked over to a display and took some food and then sat down and ate the food, and he tried to charge her, she argued with him. When a man tried to take a huge stack of napkins, like this huge stack, and Hassan caught him, he didn't even seem embarrassed.
他说偷窃并不常发生。但他注意到了一种模式。当一个女人走到陈列柜旁拿走一些食物然后坐下吃的时候，他试图向她收费，她却和他争辩。当一个男人试图拿走一大叠餐巾纸，那种巨大的叠餐巾纸，哈桑抓住他时，他甚至看起来不觉得尴尬。
He got mad. He got mad at me because I said, you're not allowed to take it.
他发火了。他因为我说“你不允许拿走它”而冲我发火。
Now, the people who steal, are they good tippers or bad? Like, the woman with the salt and pepper shaker, would they tip?
现在，那些偷东西的人，是给小费大方的人还是吝啬的人？比如那个拿走盐瓶和胡椒瓶的女人，他们会给小费吗？
Ah, they were good tippers.
啊，他们给小费很大方。
And the lawyer with the umbrella-- good tipper or bad?
那个拿雨伞的律师呢——大方还是吝啬？
No way.
绝对没有。
No way?
没给？
No way.
没给。
A lawyer?
一个律师？
That's why he has two houses.
所以他才有两栋房子。
Which brings us to the ninth commandment. This hour is going so fast. Ninth commandment, "Do not bear false witness." Don't lie. To understand this next story, you have to understand this idea of a mitzvah. For religious Jews, a mitzvah is a good deed. They're supposed to fill their days doing these good deeds.
这就引出了第九条诫命。这一个小时过得太快了。第九条诫命，“不可作假见证。”不要说谎。要理解下一个故事，你必须理解“米茨瓦”（mitzvah）的概念。对于虔诚的犹太人来说，米茨瓦就是善行。他们应该整天行善。
But mitzvah is also the Hebrew word for commandment. And remember, religious Jews count the commandments in the Bible-- they don't just have the big 10. They count, specifically, 613 commandments they're supposed to follow.
但“米茨瓦”也是希伯来语中“诫命”的意思。记住，虔诚的犹太人计算圣经中的诫命——他们不仅有十条大诫命。他们总共计算了613条必须遵守的诫命。
Well, the woman in this next story wanted to do one of the biggest mitzvot ever. She was going to save somebody's life-- a stranger's life. But to do this, she was going to have to break another one of the commandments, the one about lying. In this case, she was going to be lying to her own mother. Sarah Koenig tells more.
好吧，下一个故事中的这位女性想做一件有史以来最伟大的善行之一。她要去救某人的生命——一个陌生人的生命。但要做到这一点，她必须打破另一条诫命，即关于说谎的那一条。在这种情况下，她要对自己母亲说谎。莎拉·柯尼格讲述了更多。
Chaya Lipschutz does all her mother's shopping. She prepares all her meals for her, does all her cooking, and they're extremely close. Best friends, Chaya says. And she means it.
查雅·利普舒茨负责母亲所有的采购。她为她准备所有餐点，做所有的饭，她们非常亲密。查雅说她们是最好的朋友。她是认真的。
And they also live in this tiny space together, a two-room basement apartment in Borough Park in Brooklyn, where they share a tiny bedroom and sleep in two tiny beds-- really cots-- that are about a foot apart from each other. In this kind of setup, it's unimaginable that you could keep anything from your mother.
她们还住在同一个狭小的空间里，布鲁克林区博罗公园的一间两室地下室公寓，她们共享一个细小的卧室，睡在两个仅仅相距一英尺的小床上——实际上是简易床。在这种设置下，你很难想象能对母亲隐瞒什么。
But Chaya had this whopper of a secret. She wanted to donate a kidney to someone, to a stranger, after seeing an ad in a Jewish newspaper taken out by somebody who needed one.
但查雅有个天大的秘密。她想给某人捐献一个肾脏，给一个陌生人，在看到犹太报纸上由一个急需肾脏的人登的广告后。
The ad was, like, screaming out to me. It said, save a life, be m'chaim, which means to fulfill a once-in-a-lifetime mitzvah.
那个广告就像是在对我尖叫。它说，拯救一个生命，成为“m'chaim”，意思就是完成一生一次的米茨瓦。
It would be an uber-mitzvah. And she was going to do it, unless her mother found out first. Her mother has a kind of phobia about surgery. And also, like any parent, she would worry about all the things that could go wrong.
那将是一项超级米茨瓦。她决定要去做，除非她母亲先发现。她母亲对做手术有一种恐惧症。而且，像任何父母一样，她会担心所有可能出错的事情。
So Chaya didn't tell her mother about her plan, which took many, many months to put together. And she got away with it until her mother found some ads about kidney donation that Chaya accidentally left on the kitchen table. She lectured Chaya about it.
所以查雅没有告诉母亲她的计划，这个计划花了整整好几个月来准备。她一直瞒天过海，直到她母亲偶然发现了查雅不小心留在餐桌上的关于肾脏捐献的广告。她为此教训了查雅。
It's not for you. I think she said to me, like, you can do any other mitzvah except this one. She just, like, did-- I didn't answer her.
这不是为你准备的。我想她对我说是这样的，你做任何其他米茨瓦都可以，除了这一项。她只是——我没有回答她。
Well, but-- I mean, how old were you at this point?
好吧，但是——我的意思是，你那时多大了？
No, I mean, this was only-- yeah, I mean, right. I'm an adult. You know, I'm a grown up.
不，我的意思是，这只是——是的，我的意思是，没错。我是个成年人。你知道，我是个大人了。
She can't forbid you to do anything, really.
她确实不能禁止你做任何事。
You know what? But you know what? I didn't want to cause her any pain or any suffering. Don't forget, she's an older lady. And you know, people sometimes are frightened, and have heart attacks, and die. And I wanted to give a life. I didn't want to take away a life at the same time. But even if she didn't have a heart attack, it would give her so much suffering. And I didn't want to-- I never, ever liked to upset her.
你知道吗？但你知道吗？我不想给她带来任何痛苦或折磨。别忘了，她是位老人家。而且你知道，人们有时会害怕，会心脏病发作，会死亡。我想给予生命。我不想在同一时间夺走一条生命。但即使她没有心脏病发作，这也会带给她很多痛苦。我不想——我从来、从来都不喜欢惹她生气。
Chaya tried to follow the commandment about not lying. For her, lying is a sin, never mind lying to your own mother. She could argue that not saying anything about the kidney transplant wasn't strictly lying, but as the surgery date got closer, Chaya couldn't cling to that technicality. She was getting a lot of phone calls. She had to go for medical tests all the time.
查雅试图遵守关于不说谎的诫命。对她来说，说谎是种罪，更不用说对自己的母亲说谎。她可以争辩说对肾脏移植只字不提不算严格意义上的说谎，但随着手术日期临近，查雅无法再坚持这种技术性解释。她接到了很多电话。她必须一直去进行医疗检查。
When you would go out and get tests and do these things, where would you tell her you were going?
当你出去检查做这些事情时，你会告诉她你要去哪儿？
Well, I did-- I had to say other things. You're dragging it out of me. OK. OK. You know what? I did have to give little white lies.
好吧，我确实——我不得不说些别的东西。你非要从我嘴里撬出来。好吧。好吧。你知道吗？我确实不得不说了一些小小的善意谎言。
And what were the white lies? Like, what kinds of things would you say?
那些善意谎言是什么？比如，你会说些什么？
I don't even want to go into details. I'm embarrassed. It wasn't bad. I mean, I don't tell her anything bad, you know, like-- you know.
我甚至不想细说。我很尴尬。那不算坏。我的意思是，我不会告诉她任何坏事，你知道，就像——你知道。
Chaya feels so guilty that she lied to her mother she can barely talk about it. And the lies just became more overt as the day of the surgery arrived.
查雅对欺骗母亲感到如此愧疚，几乎无法谈论它。随着手术日的到来，谎言变得更加公开。
I had to spend the night before near the hospital.
我必须在手术前一天晚上住在医院附近。
What did you tell her?
你跟她说了什么？
Oh, gosh. I told her I was going to go to a friend's house. It was a house. And my friend was there-- the person I was donating a kidney to, she was like a friend already. So-- oh, gosh.
噢，天哪。我告诉她我要去朋友家。那是个房子。我的朋友在那里——我捐肾的对象，她已经像个朋友了。所以——噢，天哪。
I had this huge bag, you know, to bring with me to the hospital. Because I didn't want her to see how much I was taking, when my mother went to the bathroom that night before I left the house, I took my stuff, I think, out to the side of the house.
我有一个巨大的包，你知道，带去医院。因为我不想让她看到我带了多少东西，当手术前一天晚上我母亲去洗手间时，我拿着我的东西，我想，到了屋子外面。
And left it there?
然后把它留在那里？
And left it there. And then I went back in the house. So this way, you know, I just-- I didn't leave with that much, maybe a shopping bag, to go-- oh, gosh.
留在那里。然后我回到屋里。所以这样，你知道，我——我离开时没带多少东西，也许就是一个购物袋，去——噢，天哪。
But you know what? So that was hard for me, because I don't like to lie. But that-- it was all to do a good thing. It wasn't anything selfish.
但你知道吗？所以那对我来说很艰难，因为我不喜欢说谎。但那——那一切都是为了做一件好事。那不是自私的。
You know what I mean? It was all-- you know, sometimes you're-- listen, I don't want people to think you're allowed to do white lies, but sometimes you have to. Sometimes you have to. You have no choice. I'm doing this to save another person's life, so I'm sure, as a result of what I did, God's going to forgive me for all those white lies.
你懂我的意思吗？那一切都是——你知道，有时你是——听着，我不希望人们认为你可以撒小谎，但有时你必须这么做。有时你必须这样做。你没有选择。我这样做是为了挽救另一个人的生命，所以我确信，作为我所做之事的后果，上帝会原谅我所有那些小谎言。
It's one thing to plan to donate your kidney and not tell your mother. It's another thing to actually have your organ removed and not tell your mother. So Chaya had to figure out some way to break it to her once it was a done deal. And her scheme for doing this is so complicated, it makes all the earlier lies look really junior varsity. What happened is that, by chance, the same week of her surgery, somebody told Chaya about this 23-year-old Hasidic woman who had also donated a kidney to a stranger.
计划捐肾不告诉母亲是一回事。真正把器官切除却不告诉母亲又是另一回事。所以查雅必须想办法在事情已经搞定后向她坦白。她策划这件事的过程如此复杂，让之前所有的谎言看起来都像业余爱好。发生的情况是，机缘巧合，在她手术的同一周，有人告诉查雅有一个23岁的哈西德女性也给陌生人捐了肾。
And I met this very lovely young woman, Feigi. I said to her, would you be willing to tell my mother-- to come over to my mother's house after the surgery and tell her that she donated a kidney and then tell her, by the way, I donated a kidney, and I'm in the hospital right now? Like, let her be the one to tell her because my mother will see that she's healthy, she looks healthy, and she's young, and she doesn't look like she had major surgery a few months earlier.
我遇到了这位非常可爱的年轻女性，菲吉。我对她说，你愿意告诉我的母亲吗——在手术后去我母亲家，告诉她你捐了一个肾，然后告诉她，顺便说一下，我也捐了一个肾，我现在就在医院里？就像，让她成为告诉母亲那个人，因为我母亲会看到她很健康，她看起来很健康，而且她很年轻，看起来不像几个月前刚做过大手术的样子。
And so I told her, call my mother and tell her this way that you have tzedakah-- charity-- to give to one of my mother's charities. And that was a good way to get into the house. And I arranged it that my kidney recipient's family is going to call her after the surgery.
所以我告诉她，打电话给我母亲，用这种方式告诉她，你有“tzedakah”——慈善——要捐给我母亲的一个慈善机构。那是进屋的一个好办法。我安排好我肾脏接受者的家人在手术后给她打电话。
So she called my mother. And my mother was almost out the door. And she says, no, please. Please wait. I have tzedakah to give-- the charity to give to one of your charities. And of course, my mother waited.
于是她给我母亲打了电话。我母亲快要出门了。她说，不，请等一下。请等一下。我有tzedakah要捐——捐给你的一个慈善机构。当然，我母亲等待了。
And so she sat down with her, and she said she donated a kidney. And my mother looked at her up and down and says, she's normal and healthy and she just did something like that three months earlier. And she came with a cute little baby. And then she said to her, by the way, your daughter's right now in the hospital, and she did the same thing.
于是她坐下来，说她捐了一个肾。我母亲上下打量她说，她看起来正常又健康，而且三个月前刚做了那种事。她还带着一个可爱的婴儿。然后她对母亲说，顺便说一下，你女儿现在就在医院里，她也做了同样的事情。
To everyone's relief, Chaya's mother did not have a heart attack.
让所有人欣慰的是，查雅的母亲没有心脏病发作。
My mother smiled, and she said, it's mena shamayim. It's from heaven. It's heaven. You know, it's a heavenly thing that was meant to be.
我母亲笑了，她说，这是“mena shamayim”。这是来自天堂的。这是天堂。你知道，这是命中注定的天堂之事。
And she took it very, very well, just like I thought. It was like it was just exactly according to my script, the way everything worked out. And she was happy. She was happy. And you know I was so happy it was all over, and that she took it well. And she was proud of me. And it was such a relief.
她接受得非常、非常从容，就像我想的那样。就像一切都完全按照我的剧本进行一样。她很高兴。她很高兴。而且你知道我很高兴这一切都结束了，她接受得很好。她为我感到骄傲。那真是一种解脱。
It sounds like dealing with your mother was so much harder than actually donating a kidney.
听起来应付你母亲比真的捐肾难多了。
Exactly! Donating a kidney was easy for me. The hardest part was not telling my mother.
完全正确！捐肾对我来说很容易。最难的部分是不告诉母亲。
Chaya's mother never said anything to her about the white lies. And Chaya's still not sure she even knows about them. And she never chastised Chaya for keeping the surgery from her. She's just proud of Chaya, which is what Chaya wanted all along. Last month, Chaya's brother, inspired by her, donated his kidney to a stranger. He said his mother had no problem with it at all.
查雅的母亲从未对她提起过那些善意谎言。查雅仍然不确定她是否知道那些谎言。她从未责怪查雅隐瞒手术。她只是为查雅感到骄傲，这正是查雅一直想要的。上个月，查雅的兄弟深受她的鼓舞，给一个陌生人捐了他的肾。他说母亲对此一点问题都没有。
Sarah Koenig. She's the host of "Serial." In the year since we first broadcast this story, Chaya's mom has died. She continued to be proud of Chaya's decision and said she'd have probably donated a kidney herself if she were younger.
莎拉·柯尼格。她是《Serial》的主持人。在我们首次播出这个故事的一年里，查雅的母亲去世了。她一直为查雅的决定感到骄傲，并说如果她再年轻点，她可能也会自己捐一个肾。
And so we arrive at the end of our list, the end of God's to-do list for humanity, commandment number 10.
这样我们来到了清单的尽头，上帝给人类的任务清单的末尾，第十条诫命。
Like iPods, everybody wants iPods. IPods, iPods-- it's really important.
就像iPod，每个人都想要iPod。iPod，iPod——真的很重要。
"That shalt not covet thy neighbor's house. Thou shalt not covet thy neighbor's wife, nor his manservant, nor his maidservant, nor his ox, nor his ass.
“不可贪恋人的房屋。也不可贪恋人的妻子、仆婢、牛驴，并他一切所有的。”
You want phones. You want iPods. You want shoes. You want clothes. And it's a lot of things that's really important.
你想要手机。你想要iPod。你想要鞋子。你想要衣服。那有很多真的很重要的东西。
You shouldn't covet anything that is thy neighbor's.
你不应该贪恋邻居的任何东西。
So it's kind of hard for a lot of people to fit in because they want that same stuff.
所以很多人很难融入，因为他们想要同样的东西。
Amy and her friends, Selena and Kayla, are in seventh grade. During their lunch break, they explained that the latest thing that they all covet is a Sidekick 3. Which, if you haven't seen it is a kind of souped-up cell phone. They want Sidekick 3s so bad that they cannot help but notice every single person who has one.
艾米和她的朋友赛琳娜和凯拉在上七年级。在午餐休息时间，她们解释说她们最近都垂涎的东西是Sidekick 3。如果你还没见过的话，那是一种升级版的手机。她们太想要Sidekick 3了，以至于不由自主地注意到每一个拥有它的人。
Well, she's not in my class, but her name is Arlene.
嗯，她不在我的班级，但她的名字叫阿琳。
My friend, Amanda, has a Sidekick. My cousin has a Sidekick. Arlene has a Sidekick.
我朋友阿曼达有一个Sidekick。我表亲有一个Sidekick。阿琳有一个Sidekick。
Christine has a Sidekick.
克里斯汀有一个Sidekick。
Yeah, Christine has a Sidekick. Who else got a Sidekick? This girl on the train got a Sidekick. I saw her Sidekick. Yeah. Like, almost all my family got a Sidekick. I want a Sidekick. I don't have a Sidekick. I lost my phone, actually. But I want a Sidekick. But I don't got it yet. See-- yeah, she has one. Yeah, she has one.
是的，克里斯汀有一个Sidekick。还有谁有Sidekick？火车上的那个女孩有一个Sidekick。我看到了她的Sidekick。是的。就像，我家里几乎所有人都有Sidekick。我想要一个Sidekick。我没有Sidekick。事实上我弄丢了我的手机。但我想要一个Sidekick。但我还没拿到。你看——是的，她有一个。是的，她有一个。
You have a Sidekick. Can we see?
你有一个Sidekick。能看看吗？
This girl, Christine, pulls out her Sidekick and shows it around. The photo on the Sidekick's little display is herself, which definitely is one of those things that is normal when a kid does it but would be so weird if an adult tried it. She hasn't had the Sidekick for very long.
那个女孩，克里斯汀，掏出她的Sidekick展示给大家看。Sidekick小屏幕上的照片是她自己，这绝对是小孩子做这种事很正常，但如果是成年人尝试就会很怪的那种事情。她拿到Sidekick的时间还不长。
I don't really remember. I think it was in the beginning of April.
我不记得了。我想是在四月初。
Oh, so just a couple weeks ago.
噢，也就是几周前。
Yeah. It's cool, actually, because I get to go on the internet, and I get to go on AOL.
是的。其实这很酷，因为我可以上网，可以上AOL。
Text message.
发短信。
Text message. All that. It's really good. It's like an extra computer, a little computer, for myself to carry around.
发短信。所有这些。真的很棒。就像额外的一台电脑，一台我可以随身携带的小电脑。
A portable everything. A portable everything, basically.
便携式的一切。基本上就是便携式的一切。
And did you want one for a long time?
你想要这个很久了吗？
Yeah, actually I did.
是的，其实是。
Now, were there people who didn't talk to you before the Sidekick, who when you got the Sidekick--
现在，有没有人以前不跟你说话，当你拿到Sidekick后——
Yeah. There was a lot of people that didn't talk to me. And now that I have my Sidekick, they, like, every day want to use
有的。有很多以前不跟我说话的人。现在我有了Sidekick，他们每天都想用。
So they just want to use the Sidekick? They don't want to actually--
所以他们只是想用Sidekick？他们并不真的想——
Yeah, they just want the Sidekick. They don't want me. It's the Sidekick.
是的，他们只是想要Sidekick。他们不想要我。就是那个Sidekick。
These girls actually had a very grown-up attitude about all this stuff they covet. This stuff matters to them, but it doesn't totally matter. Kayla was wearing Nikes or Cons, and nobody cared. Selena and Amy recently got iPods, and they're the first to admit it didn't change how anybody saw them. I remind them that it's in the Bible that we're not supposed to want stuff or be jealous of people who have stuff we don't have.
这些女孩对她们所垂涎的这些东西其实有种非常成熟的态度。这些东西对她们很重要，但并没有完全压倒一切。凯拉穿的是耐克或匡威，没人关心。赛琳娜和艾米最近买了iPod，她们也是第一批承认这并没改变别人看她们眼光的人。我提醒她们，圣经中说我们不应该贪恋东西，或者嫉妒那些有我们没有的东西的人。
Do you think it's realistic that people aren't going to want stuff?
你觉得人们不去想要东西是现实的吗？
No, because everybody want stuff at some point.
不，因为每个人在某个时候都想要东西。
I think it's just natural. Like, everybody is going to want something in life. You know, you're not going to go through life not wanting anything. You're not going to just go through life, OK, I have this, and I have that. I don't need anything else. Or I don't want this. I think it's just natural for people to want things.
我认为这很自然。就像，每个人生活中总会想要点什么。你知道，你不可能一生什么都不想要。你不可能就那样过一生，好吧，我有这个，我有那个。我不需要别的东西。或者我不想要这个。我认为人们想要东西是很自然的。
But then you're saying, in a way, it's natural that we're always going to be breaking one of the Ten Commandments.
但这样说来，我们在某种程度上一直在打破十诫之一，是很自然的。
Basically, yeah.
基本上是这样。
If we needed any proof of this, that we're always going to want stuff and sometimes we're going to want stuff that we probably shouldn't, it was just a few feet away. A girl named Nadie had written on her arm, down the length of arm, "Nadie N David." That's N-- the letter N-- with a heart underneath it.
如果我们需要证明我们总会想要东西，而且有时会想要我们可能不该要的东西，那就在几英尺远的地方。一个叫纳迪的女孩在胳膊上顺着胳膊写着“Nadie N David”。就是N——字母N——下面画个心形。
That's my boyfriend.
那是我的男朋友。
And is he in your grade?
他是你同年级的吗？
Nah, he's older than me. He's two years older than me.
不，他比我大。他比我大两岁。
Talk about him.
谈谈他。
That's her girlfriend, egging her on.
那是她的女朋友，在怂恿她。
He's nice. You know, I broke up with him once. Well, we're going back out.
他很好。你知道，我跟他分手过一次。嗯，我们又和好了。
And he broke her heart. But I don't think she should be going out with him, because she's messed up. I'm mad at her.
但他伤了她的心。但我觉得她不该跟他在一起，因为她脑子坏了。我为她生气。
Because people were saying that he talked [BLEEP] about me.
因为有人说他谈论我不好的事（消音）。
Yeah, it's true. It's true.
是的，这是真的。这是真的。
But I love him, so--
但我爱他，所以——
You don't know what love is, Nadie. That's not till you get to 16. Look, that's David over there. That's David over there. Look. He's with another girl. Oh! With the one in black.
你根本不知道什么是爱，纳迪。那要等到16岁。看，那是大卫。那是大卫在那儿。看。他和另一个女孩在一起。噢！那个穿黑衣服的。
He's walking arm in arm with another girl.
他正和另一个女孩手挽手走着。
OK, see.
好，你看。
David!
大卫！
Right there. That's it, right there. See, that's what make us be mad.
就在那儿。就是那样，就在那儿。看，那就是让我们生气的原因。
Oh, my god, Nadie. You see him right there, you don't say nothing. That's messed up right there. Yo, that's messed up.
天哪，纳迪。你看见他就在那儿，你什么都不说。那太乱了。哟，那太乱了。
Catechism of the Catholic church says, the Tenth Commandment concerns the intentions of the heart. The catechism talks about desires that are often good, wholesome desires but go on to exceed the limits of reason and make us want things too much, especially things that really belong to somebody else. Wanting things too much, it says, is a form of sadness. And the Tenth Commandment, that's what it's trying to eradicate.
《天主教教理》说，第十条诫命关乎内心的意向。《教理》谈到了那些通常是好的、健康的愿望，但它们往往超出了理性的界限，让我们贪求过分，特别是那些真正属于别人的东西。过分贪求，它说，是一种忧伤。而第十条诫命，正是试图消除这种忧伤。
Our program was produced today by Jane Marie and myself with Alex Blumberg, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Senior producer for today's show, Julie Snyder. Production help from Seth Lind, Tommy Andres, and Emily Youssef. Additional production by Aviva DeKornfeld, Ray Mondo, Stone Nelson, and Matt Tierney.
今天的节目由简·玛丽和我自己制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格、莎拉·柯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克共同参与。今天节目的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。制作协助来自塞斯·林德、汤米·安德烈斯和艾米莉·尤瑟夫。额外制作由阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德、雷·蒙多、斯通·尼尔森和马特·蒂尔尼完成。
Music help today from Jessica Hopper. Mary Robertson produced our story about the Ninth Commandment. Thanks today to Liebman's Deli in the Bronx, where we taped the story for the Eighth Commandment about stealing. Thanks to Middle School 51 in Brooklyn, where we taped our Tenth Commandment story, especially to one of the seventh grade teachers who worked there back when we did this show, Andrew Raven.
感谢杰西卡·霍珀提供的音乐协助。玛丽·罗伯逊制作了我们关于第九条诫命的故事。感谢今天提供帮助的布朗克斯区的利布曼熟食店，我们在那里录制了第八条诫命关于偷盗的故事。感谢布鲁克林51中学，我们在那里录制了第十条诫命的故事，特别感谢我们做这期节目时在那里任教的七年级老师之一，安德鲁·雷文。
"This American Life" is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he says that when he goes home, he sees the mailings from our own public radio station that arrive at his house pile up in his front hallway, asking for money, and he cannot help himself. He just has to pledge.
《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）分发给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。你知道，他说当他回家时，看到我们自己的公共广播电台寄来的邮件堆在他前厅，要求捐款，他情不自禁。他不得不认捐。
If you're a guy with a similar struggle, ask your wife or mother to help you in this area by ridding your home of these unnecessary temptations.
如果你是一个有类似挣扎的男士，请寻求你的妻子或母亲在这一领域的帮助，清理掉你家中的这些不必要的诱惑。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of "This American Life."
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。